et en direct dans cette édition
l'éditorialiste alexis poulain co
fondateur du site d'information le monde
moderne bonjour alexis merci de répondre
à nos questions donc le sénat qui votent
ce matin de la prorogation de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire jusqu'au 31 janvier
et non jusqu'au 16 février comme le
souhaitait le gouvernement
camouflet pour l'exécutif ou simple
parcours administratif de ce texte doit
maintenant être qui doit trouver une
mouture en commun alors camoufler non
mais au moins non pas un simulacre de
démocratie mais un vrai contre-pouvoir
en lieu du sénat et c'est pas la
première fois d'ailleurs que le sénat
joue son rôle de chambre haute pour
retoquer des textes jugés mal fait et
peu enclin à entrer en vigueur donc tant
mieux ça permet de déboucher sur
davantage de débats démocratiques
davantage de dialogue et d'avoir un
texte qui va être à minima pour rogner
sur nos libertés fondamentales parce que
le risque de ces lois d'exception bien
entendu c'est de réduire toujours plus
de liberté dans cette lutte effrénée
contre le virus qui visiblement passe
davantage par plus de paperasse plus de
confinement que par plus de lits plus de
soignants plus de mesures sanitaires
autre que celle d' empêcher les gens
d'aller et venir
donc tant mieux si le sénat est dans son
rôle
justement le confinement il devrait
prendre fin le 8 décembre
si on se fie à l'amendement des
sénateurs votre avis sur ce confinement
généralisée il était inévitable
il était tout à fait évitable si la
rentrée avait été préparée quand on
entend jean michel blanquer aujourd'hui
égrainé un lait les mesures qui sont
prises avec trois mois de retard et bien
voilà pourquoi nous sommes confinés
aujourd'hui parce que jean-michel le
caire a passé l'été comme une cigale a
chanté tout l'été plutôt que préparer
cette rentrée où les enfants se sont
entassés à l'université dans des classes
bondées sans mesures sanitaires adaptés
et on a fait en fait des bombes à
retardement dco vide puisque ces enfants
ensuite et soie étaient malades
eux-mêmes infecter les professeurs et
puis les familles se sont infectés et
tout ça a été fait avec une désinvolture
qui à l'époque choqué les soignants qui
ne comprenaient pas en fait que cette
rentrée soit si mal organisé donc nous
voilà dans un deuxième confinement comme
6 mars n'avait pas eu lieu comme si
c'est peut-être inéluctable et bien non
c'était tout à fait évitable si la
rentrée je le dis bien avait été préparé
et ce n'a pas été le cas
par ce gouvernement est aujourd'hui et
bien il ne ratera pas leur retard
il continue de faire ce qu'ils ne se
faire uniquement c'est-à-dire confiner
les gens faire fermer les commerces et
les indemniser non pas hauteur de ce que
seraient les profits pour ses commerces
oui c'est vraiment par rapport à
l'indemnisation quid du plan de relance
du gouvernement qui ne prévoyait pas de
confinement
voilà le plan de relance qui est censé
être sur du moyen et long terme
quand on entend parler françois bayrou
il ne parle que de court terme on voit
bien que partout l'idée d'un état
stratège a totalement déserté les têtes
de nos leaders et de nos responsables
politiques
pour eux il s'agit de gérer au coup par
coup à à la minute souvent avec plus de
quinze jours à mois de retard plutôt que
de planifier préparer s'assurer que les
moyens pour les soignants sont pas à la
hauteur que l'information en urgence de
réanimateurs pour elle pouvait être fait
elle n'a pas été fait
rien n'a été préparé pour la rentrée et
donc à chaque fois on est dans l'urgence
on est avec deux coups de retard et on
se retrouve à faire des mesures qui vont
coûter très cher bruno le maire par de
15 à 20 milliards supplémentaires sur la
table pour aider les entreprises mais
les entreprises ne vont jamais rentrés
dans leurs frais
compte tenu de cette fin d'année où il
ya beaucoup c'est un moment important
pour pour les commerces
eh bien là c'est une mise à mort de
beaucoup de secteurs transports mais
aussi les bars les restaurants le
secteur de la culture extrêmement
impacté le secteur de l'événementiel
pour cela évident série non justement
alexis poplin vous parler un de ces 15
milliards dead on a entendu bruno
mr égrainé les différents points pour
pour soutenir les commerces et salariés
impactés donc par cette crise sanitaire
15 milliards avec ses 10000 euros 1 par
mois pour les entreprises de moins de 50
salariés par exemple on a l'impression
que c'est peu pour ces entreprises qui
font face à des dettes incommensurable
mais on a l'impression que c'est énorme
également quand on met tout ça bout
tabou
donc à la fois peu et à la fois énorme
pour financer comment est-ce que vous
l'expliquer et qui va pouvoir financer
autant d'argent et c'est un pis-aller là
il s'agit simplement de faire croire que
le gouvernement va aider des secteurs
qu'il est en train de détruire par ce
confinement qui aurait pu être évitée
donc il s'agit de d'une aumône qui va
durer le temps qu'elle durera tout comme
le chômage partiel qui a été prolongée
mais mais tout cela ne va pas empêcher
des nombreuses faillites qui vont se
succéder et aussi le nombre de
travailleurs précaires qui rentrent
maintenant qu'ils quittent les rives du
chômage pour entrer dans le rsa dans le
des moments plus difficiles parce qu'il
y aura comme vous le disiez le pib se
contracte la croissance se contracte
donc finalement les perspectives sont
plutôt sombres pour l'emploi est
extrêmement difficile pour ses nombreux
commerces qui n'auront pas d'autre choix
à partir de l'an prochain que de mettre
la clé sous la porte parce que
l'activité ne reviendra faire mais je
crois que la france aujourd'hui est un
des pays les moins bien placés
effectivement et à parfaire une dette
incommensurable ce que font aujourd'hui
nos leaders en de finalement les trois
pour cent tout ça n'existe plus il
s'agit d'argent magique mais la réalité
c'est que nous sommes en train avec ce
gouvernement d'aller droit dans le mur
d'une banqueroute économique et d'une
faillite généralisée organisé par ces
confinement à répétition dernière
question alexis poulain conseil de
défense aujourd'hui à l'elysée
évidemment au sujet de l'attentât de 10
heures de nice mais aussi monsieur j'ai
de la crise sanitaire qu'est ce qu'il
faut en attendre justement sujet on
verra bien sûr les annonces ces conseils
de défense ils sont devenus quotidiens
quasiment c'est vous dire l'état du pays
c'est vous dire aussi à quoi finalement
servent les conseils des ministres on
est en train de se demander finalement
si tout n'est pas gérée dans ces
conseils de défense dans la tête d'un
seul emmanuel macron qui décide de tout
comme un roi à l'elysée et donc c'est
assez inquiétant parce que derrière pour
la lutte contre le terrorisme on a
besoin de tous les services mobilisés
on a besoin aussi d'un plan stratégique
on a vu un immédiatement hier après
l'attentât de nice l'augmentation des
moyens de vigipirate
l'augmentation aussi du niveau de
vigilance des dispositifs mis en place
mais quelles vont être les moyens
pérennes pour le renseignement pour la
police pour la justice également pour
s'assurer que les français sont protégés
et que nous n'allons pas avoir d'autres
attentats parce que la france est
clairement montré comme cibles par de
nombreuses agitateurs à l'international
et aussi au niveau national donc une
réponse ferme est attendue de ce côté là
et puis pour le côté sanitaire et bien
voilà nous entrons dans un nouveau
confinement et ça va être extrêmement
difficile de continuer à faire comme si
de rien n'était sachant que il faut
emmener les enfants à l'école avec des
papiers il faut aller au travail avec
des papiers enfin il ya toute une
paperasserie inutile et je pense que les
policiers ont bien mieux à faire
aujourd'hui que mettre des amendes aux
gens qui n'ont pas les papiers ou qui
enfreindrait le confinement pour aller
se promener ce week end
voilà merci alex et paulin d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes éditorialistes et co fondateur
du site d'information le monde moderne